okay everybody we're about to go live
good morning everybody and welcome to
this meeting of mid-suffolk District
Council I'm councilor Susie Morley and I
am the leader of mid-suffolk District
Council and I'll be chairing the meeting
today
I'm going to remind you of some domestic
Arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please ensure your
stuff
also your laptops are on
finally we'll be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov app so please
could members make sure they are logged
in and ready to use the app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
can I now move to the agenda please
item one apologies for absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies from councilor burn Council
Blues
Bruce thank you very much
item two is to receive Declarations of
pecuniary other registrable or
non-registerable interests by members
are there any to declare
councilor Whitehead yes I think I
probably ought to declare a non-pecuri
interest as a Gateway 14 councilor
director in agenda item 11. okay
teacher similarly I need to declare an
opportunity interest as a director as
director of Freeport East limited for
agenda item 11. okay thank you very much
item three is to confirm the minutes of
the meeting held on the 5th of December
2022 that's item MCA slash 22 33.
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
could I have a proposer please
all right
cancer-flatman and the second
councilor Whitehead
governance officer will now conduct the
vote
thank you chair that brought us now in
progress
councilor Fleming
thank you chair that vote is unanimous
thank you very much
item four is to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
none received thank you item five
questions by councilors
none received
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or the joint audit
and standards committee they are no
matters referred chair
thank you
item seven is the forthcoming decisions
list are there any comments on this
no thank you very much
so the first main item substantive item
on the agenda is item eight MCA slash 22
34 council tax reduction brackets
working age scheme for 2023-24.
um
in attendance we've got Melissa Evans
the director of corporate resources and
Amy Mays the shared Revenue partnership
operations manager and I'm now going to
invite the cabinet member for finance to
introduce this report councilor my Ted
uh thank you madam chairman
the first of my two reports this morning
I'd like to introduce paper MCA 2234 on
the council tax reduction working age
scheme 20
24.
the fundamentals behind the proposed
changes to our local council tax
reduction scheme for those of working
age were put before cabinet back in
October last year in report MCA 2223
and then my introduction to that report
I set out the various principles
involved and the arguments in favor of
our selection of options three from the
choice of the four options detailed in
that report
I therefore do not intend to rehearse
all that again today however is the
referral the three options that
envisaged to change from the current
scheme are set out in appendix is a to c
of today's report
about cabinet meeting our director for
corporate resources was authorized to
initiate the formal consultation process
that is a statue requirement before any
final decisions can be made on any
proposed revisions to the scheme
now that six week consultation period
process has now been carried out
the results that survey are set out in
appendix D and I think the answers to
all the 15 questions posed from the 53
people who responded do make interesting
reading
all respondents were Council taxpayers
in Mississippi
and only 28 of those responding benefit
from the present reduction scheme so
over two-thirds of all respondents are
paying council tax at a full
contribution rate
now at 79 percent nearly 4 out of five
every respondents supported a move to a
maximum 100 reduction and an even higher
percentage 91 percent support is
simplifying the scheme and reduce using
Administration costs
three people is a small sample but their
responses endorse the conclusions that
we reached as a Cabinet back in October
and I would add further that these
cushions that I have had when reporting
on this matter at
meetings of several Parish councils in
the meantime were likewise strongly in
favor
the arguments for a simplification in
the present cumbersome Administration
process when taken into conjunction with
the help that a maximum 100 reduction
will provide some are more financially
challenged residents does seem quite
conclusive to me
therefore I'd like to move the
recommendations in paragraph 3.1 of the
report that options three set out an
appendix C be used as a basis for a
revised council tax reduction working
age scheme for the year 23-24.
thank you
thank you chair I'm happy to Second
um I totally support the recommendation
and this will make council tax payments
more for customer friendly for those on
variable income which is very
complicated and it means it goes up and
down up and down monthly and and it's
very difficult to keep track of it all
and it's also an awful lot of
uh officer time sorting out these
different
um tax rates each month for a lot of
people thank you Tim
thank you councilor Platinum do we have
any questions from
from questions from other members
Council Gill
thank you uh
it's obviously advocating good common
sense I'm not going to question any of
those uh real issues but just a form for
clarification I was looking at table
three on
page 20 and just above that there's a
table of the costs to various bodies I
think I understand the County Council
and we can't commissioner and probably
even mid-suffolk I was just a bit
concerned about the parish average it's
his Parish average do I assume that 6.6
K is the cost
accumulated across all parishes or is
that the cost of predict to a particular
parishes which happen to be victims of
this scheme or
I guess the answer is it's the title but
just wanted to be sure and
an aside question is there any are there
any parishes that suffer extraordinarily
under this you know have a large number
of people who will be exempt council tax
and therefore
suffer a large charge or or can I
cheerfully divide 6.6 Kai by whatever it
is 70 or something cancers and account
parishes and decide the cost per is
Trivial thank you
uh thank you for your question
um my understanding is a 6.6
000 cost to the parish is a total for in
fact all town and Parish councils Within
mid-suffolk
um and obviously some well some Parish
meetings collect nothing others still
Market obviously have a figure probably
close to if not a higher than mid
Suffolk so it will vary
um by Parish to Parish without not aware
of that any particular Parish will
suffer particularly more than any other
thank you chair um just a question
really looking forward
um what what's going to be done to
monitor this throughout this year so
that
um because this is for one year only I
believe
um is there a possibility that that it
might be continued for the following
year and what's going to be done in the
meantime to monitor
uh how the how this change in the Stream
is is progressing please
thank you to tell you Michael
um right
um well I mean there are two aspects to
this is the 100 reduction to 100 maximum
and the simplification process
simplification process is there for the
duration
and so um in terms of the 100 move
that's the short term
um one year
um alteration but I think I
just like to bring in AIM if you don't
mind to just extrapolate a bit further
in terms of how it might be monitored
and the
effects
um the council tax reduction scheme is
agreed and can be reviewed every year so
in terms of how how we monitor it
obviously the amount of council tax
reduction that we give is calculated and
awarded on a daily basis
case load itself changes on a daily
basis as the needs of our customers
changes so we we are constantly
monitoring the cost of the scheme and
the caseload that we support
moving forward if we look to change the
scheme next year then I will be coming
back to council to the cabinet in the
summer
to be able to tell you then what the
caseload is and what the needs of our
customers will be and we will look then
what proposals we will have for the
24-25 year and whether we need to go out
to consultation again
councilor field
sorry to come back but just one other
point I lost all of my annotations
at the moment
um just a question about the um the
actual operational savings uh 70 it says
75 to 150 000 pounds that's quite a
broad uh estimate I I wanted to uh do
you expect to come in near the bottom or
near the top or or even do better than
that
um and is that the savings which
which as either the total administrative
savings which will be spread across
mid-suffolk the county and God knows who
else or is that just a particular
element of those savings thank you
thank you um well I understand the sort
of basic principle behind
um you know what's driving those savings
and obviously it's it's at the moment of
forecast as to how the situation and how
the administration of the scheme will
change but again if I could just bring
in Amy for her forces right
thank you certainly our expectations are
that the vacancies that we're currently
carrying we will be able to disestablish
posts
we're covering those with additional
hours at the moment rather than
appointing people to those posts on the
expectation that a simplified scheme
will allow us to reduce the
administration costs what we're unable
to estimate is how the impact of the
scheme when it's in operation will
further impact
um
the needs for resources and of course we
have to balance that off with the
changing demands on the council tax side
we've got a lot of building going on so
we've got a lot more council tax to
collect we've had a number of other
schemes that we've had in operation so
it's very difficult to see at the moment
what the changing requirements for the
shared service will have on on an
ongoing basis but certainly the savings
that we've established at the moment are
from disestablishing vacant posts and
will be a partnership saving so will be
shared in direct proportion of course
posts
that's currently four and a half posts
thank you
so I'm now going to open up the item for
debate who wants to start
for me this is a almost a bit of a
no-brainer it costs us
far in excess to administer sending out
letters
for amounts less than a pound and the
saving that we're going to make not just
in our office of time but also in the
stress and
um
strain felt by our residents who are
getting
letters perhaps
quite on a daily basis but regularly
for small amounts that they can
so
um for me I've fully fully support this
option and I certainly will be voting
for it
nobody else wishes to discuss this
um
so the recommendations are that option
three has set out in appendix C of this
report
be used as the basis for a revised
working age council tax reduction scheme
for
2023-24 and I'm now going to ask the
governance officer to conduct the vote
thank you
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
councilor heading up um
it's about four please
sorry Council
thank you chair that is six votes four
that's unanimous
thank you very much
moving on now to item nine MCA slash 22
35 is the fees and charges report for
2023-24 and we have with us
Melissa Evans director for corporate
resources and also Rebecca Hewitt
um
also advising
thank you commissioning and procurement
thank you thank you
um so again I'm going to ask councilor
Whitehead to introduce this report
uh thank you madam chairman so for my
second report today I'd like to
introduce paper MCA 2235 on fees and
charges for 23.24
although the approval of the annual
budget is a full function of full
Council
cabinet has the authority to approve the
council's fees and charges that once
approved we baked into the draft budget
they'll be presenting to ons cabinet
then ultimately to full Council towards
the end of February
I think the first important point I need
to make is that although this fees and
charges report it's coming from myself I
can't remember finance and is under the
authorship of our section 151 office and
finance team these fees and charges are
the recommendations of the relevant
service managers
they have reviewed the fees and charges
to their relevant areas and that's the
real report explains in paragraph 5.6
they are confident that where changes
are proposed these have been benchmarked
as being reasonable
Council you must trade the fine line
between cost recovery and any
affordability issues that could lead to
a potential fall off of income from
customer price resistance
now that of course is just basic
economics
a key principle behind all this though
can be summed up in five words
aiming for a full cost recovery
and so that these discretionary services
are self-funding and not subsidized
those line items on which there are
changes to our fees and charges have
split out in the report between
statutory charges set nationally in
paragraph 5.8 and discretionary charges
set locally in paragraph 5.9
a full Suite of fees and charges and an
extensive list which runs to 18 Pages
can be found in appendix a of the report
members can also see an appendix B our
fees and charges income by service area
the top five areas of our fees and
charges are development management at
1.58 million Garden waste at 1.19
million car park income at 581 000 trade
waste at 576 000 and building
regulations chargeable services at 373
000. together those five areas make up
4.3 million or 80 percent of the total
5.407 million that the council
anticipates raising in fees and charges
during the upcoming year 23 24.
this is all vital income to the council
and that figure of 5.407 million
compares to 5.151 million in our current
year budget that's an overall increase
of five percent
as always I'm happy to answer any
questions on anything on this report and
its dependencies but before that I'd
like to move the recommendation into 3.1
that is our fees and charges are set out
in appendix a be approved by cabinet
with us for a second due to that
recommendation thank you
do we have a second
the Fleming
yes thank you I'm happy to Second
um the fees and charges as set out in
our papers
do we have any questions from cabinet
any questions from anybody else
councilor Willem
thank you chair just a couple of
questions
um one is around the bulky items
collections
um 49 pounds 50 seems quite a lot for
one item are we sure that we're not
um setting the price too high for a
single item so that people are tempted
to throw their fridge in a ditch
and the other is around High Hedges
which I was quite surprised to see on
there
um
so who who is it who would contact the
district
for to have the is it so any Resident
can have their hedge trimmed
um for 12 pounds of linear meter I was
surprised to see it is this is this just
for any resident within the the district
it seems for a short length of hedge to
be quite quite cheap
well okay I was going to say in terms of
build your item collection
um I think it's up to three items I know
when
yeah and I know when I was moving house
I needed to use this I sort of got a
neighbor to sort of go go in with me
sort of share the cost because it made
sense to try and you know utilize as
much as possible but um certainly I
found that a very useful service and um
the uh I say which which we do try to
make sure that the costs reflect sorry
charges reflect the underlying costs and
now in terms of high Hedges that's a
very interesting question because I
haven't got a clue what the answer to
that is the actual perhaps look to
either my fellow cab member for
environment or an officer to perhaps
answer that
um thank you I think um I will seek
clarification from an officer because
although I while I should know
um I don't know well enough to respond
I'm sorry we don't have an officer here
we'll respond outside the meeting yeah
happy with the written response at some
point it's not not desperately urgent
okay all right I don't have a head in
mind
familiar with the 350 pounds because
when you get someone who's neighbors got
a high H and they want it cut
350 pounds seemed like a a large
starting for your fusai but if that's
really being dropped to 12 pounds per
linear meter we go from one extreme to
tiller so so I'd rather suspect that
it's 350 pounds to start off plus 12
pounds per linear amount well leave that
to your office and to answer and I know
it's an interesting area a couple of uh
serious questions on here first of all
if I look up five point eight it says
statutory charges and immediately below
that it says discretionary charges have
seen an increase from 22 23 can be
broken down as follows so the question
is are they statutory or are they
discretionary under that heading because
I understand statutory charges are fixed
by the government so they might be
government increases the discretionary
charges are obviously fixed by us so
just not absolutely clear what those are
um
next question really is you talk about
cost recovery and that we may do this
various work on a a basis that we
totally recover costs I wonder where the
evidence for that is presented because I
couldn't see any down here and there
were things like I think as we mentioned
increasing in collection charges for
single items it's clearly expensive to
send a vehicle out but there's quite a
swinging increase to the cost of green
bin collection so where's the evidence
that we're actually recovering cost to
their log and making substantial profits
and the third issue is the impact on
inflation clearly the government at the
moment is very concerned about the
national inflation rate and clearly
that will cause increases in costs and
clearly we have to recover those to some
extent but to come up with increases
like 66.7 percent
Food hygiene score things
does seem to be that we're winding up
inflation which will be to the entire
nation's disadvantage you'll be this is
a small percentage of it so I just
wondered what is our attitude on the
impact
of inflation
on inflation as opposed to the final
comment is the one that says destruction
of surrendered food certificate
presumably that's not destruction of a
certificate which cost me 168 quid is
destruction of the food that goes with
this certificate that cost me
does have four questions sorry
right right let me is it like a memory
test
which is anything
um in terms of paragraph 5.8 I believe
the wording just below the word Saturday
charges is a typo and so far as it then
refers to discretionary charges
um
in terms of these sort of General
principle about the um uh cost
recoveries and how that's reflected
um there's obviously a lot of work going
on behind this in terms of for each of
these different headings
um you know there's been investigation
as to how much work is involved so for
example I think you mentioned the Food
hygiene rating rescore visits and she's
going up 108 280 pound I mean that
reflects the
it's been assessed it takes about three
hours
of an officer time to go out and do that
visit and therefore really our fees
previously were under recovering and so
although it's a hefty increase it is to
you know reflect the real cost of
providing that
and I know from conversations I've had
over the years things like the litter
bin and dog bin collections they've
always been very up being subsidized in
the past slowly but surely we're getting
by Modest increases year on year we get
into a situation where we're getting
closer and closer to a full cost
recovery there but I suspect we're still
a little short there
um but it and it's just your general
point about inflation obviously with
inflation CPI 10 or whatever now and
probably seem to be running about five
percent through rest the next year it's
it's a it's a delicate Balancing Act I
think between making sure that we do
recover our costs be cognizance of the
fact it is having the charge
particularly on businesses but
um I think in the scheme of things these
are relatively modest charges
and um
you know I still feel fully Justified
but I understand where your concerns are
coming from
I think that cover everything
uh
I would have thought it was in the in
the council's interest to provide some
evidence on perhaps one or two line
items that just shows that these
increases are not dreamed up you know
they're not not John putting his finger
in the air they've got a real basis and
clearly if you did it for everyone it
would take forever but if you picked one
or tensored I can assure you we do not
go in for fingering
I'm sure you don't but uh just in case
residents were suspicious that we did
okay
um does anybody wish to debate this item
no
okay so the recommendations are
oh sorry cancer Fatman
sorry
um thank you chair I'd just like to
reiterate um what councilor Whitehead
has said about
um the food certificate I know from
personal experience that when we have
um each the eho or the E eup come in
from councils they literally
um spend a whole morning going through
absolutely everything the records the
temperature records the refrigerator
records Etc the staff training records
They are there at least four hours
sometimes longer depending on the
premises
thank you councilman
so the recommendations are that the
proposed fees and charges for
2023-24 as shown in appendix a be
approved I'm now going to ask the
governance officer to conduct the vote
thank you chair that vote has now in
progress
um councilor headingham I'd like to
thank Paul thank you Council
thank you chair that is six books for
and that's unanimous
very much
item 10 is MCA slash
22-36 and this is the tenancy policy we
have with us Deborah Fenton director for
housing and also
who's the tenant services corporate
manager so I'm now going to invite
councilor headingham County member for
housing to introduce this report thank
you
um I'm very happy to present the
council's tenants policy for approval
today this policy sets out how tenancies
will be granted and managed in
accordance with legislation and
regulation in our Council homes
policy
consulate consolidates our current
working practices in tenancy management
and reinforces our commitment to
equality in firms the policies in line
with government policy for social
housing
security of 10 years long established
has been long established as a
fundamental aspect of social housing
however in 2011 the localism ACT
provided social landlords with the
opportunity to issue a very different
form of tenancy tenancies with lesser
security and for a fixed period of time
by doing so the government intended for
landlords to review tenants needs for
social housing on a routine basis and
require them to move to Alternative
accommodation if the property no longer
met their needs or they were no longer
were considered to have a need for
social housing labor and would Suffolk
has not Implement implemented these
tenancies instead we have continued to
Grant secure tenancies social landlords
who were early adopters of these fixed
term tenancies have not had a positive
experience and have since returned to
providing long-term security of tenancy
for a number of reasons the key ones
being that
viewing and reassuring Tendencies was
very resource incentive and bureaucratic
now the negative impact on rent Aria's
recovery
tenant circumstances really changed in
that five-year period and therefore the
policy did not generate the desired
churn to have any impact on housing
needs the review process was very
intrusive for tenants and having a Time
limited tenancy had a negative um had
had a negative on the well-being of
mental health tenants
the short-term tenancies are less
desirable resulting in reduced Mobility
by Mutual Exchange
are less likely to invest in making
their house a home investing in carpets
decorating and taking care of the
property
meanwhile following the Grenville
tragedy in 2017 government policy and
the focus on the housing sector has
placed greater emphasis on the
importance of protecting the welfare and
well-being of people in rented
accommodation
and tackling policies which lead to
social housing stigma our proposal is
therefore to continue to offer lifetime
secure tenancies as we have always done
to support tenants and their families to
make their rented property a home and
enable them to put down routes in the
local community we want to encourage and
enable our tenants to move on to smaller
and more suitable accommodation when
their needs if then when and if their
needs change on their own terms and will
bring forward a separate downsizing
incentive policy later this year
policy is being created with the help of
tenant insight and will provide
incentives to enable tenants to move on
to suitable alternative accommodation
where if then and if their needs change
we believe this tenancy policy and the
forthcoming downsizing incentive policy
will make better use of our limited
resources
both portfolio holders and offices have
been working hard to develop this
tenancy policy and that contexts and
principles of it were shared more widely
through our all-member housing briefing
on the 29th of November we need to be
clear that this imperative that we have
such a policy in place to ensure we are
compliant with the regulatory standards
for which we know there is greater
scrutiny of the management of council
housing than ever before thank you very
much
thank you councilor headingham and do we
have a secondary
chair yes I totally support the
recommendation thank you thank you
do we have any questions
questions from anybody else
councilor field
yes I'll see you no question to say we
welcome most of this
um just just a question really about a
couple of issues which I'm hoping not
sort of parochial ones but they do seem
to be some issues that certainly have
suffered over the
20 years as a counselor you know
responding to some issue so to go
through a couple of those
there seems to be an issue when
um you know
going to council house producer family
they stay in that Council house until
all day unfortunately passed away the
tenancy carries on to one of their
siblings if there are two siblings in
the family you then get the second
sibling who's unable to remain in that
accommodation and it's accommodation
that you know been in ever since they
were or since before they actually
existed so it's their lifetime
accommodation I wonder who's still happy
that this policy adequately covers those
sort of positions
um another one that sprung to mind was
the issue when you have a Partners in a
council house with children perhaps and
you know unfortunately the relationship
broke down which does occur and it sort
of reads as though one of those Partners
can ensure the family is injected from
its Council house which
occasions when Partners can be quite
aggressive and an objection of in such
circumstances and I just wondered
whether that's adequately covered so
really the broad question is you
obviously have tremendous experience of
running
this operation are you confident that
you've covered uh not only the the the
general
um
things that occur but the ones that are
somewhat lesser
likely and and which do produce genuine
mental suffering I think is the issue I
mean I think to just illustrate the you
know one of the cases I'm aware of of
the um the siblings
taking over a tenancy
the person concerned eventually
um well unfortunately done by doing an
impact between his car and a building
you know you could draw sorts of wild
conclusions from that but there did seem
to be a principle there that we can
provide a lot of stress to people on
occasion thank you
they're both those um
you know occurrence is a very
distressful and um and but I like to
think that you know this is the oh fan
obviously we have considered most things
but I will pass it on to Deborah who
said well you know I'm experiencing this
matter
thank you I'm gonna I'm gonna let my
colleague um Rob
um provide some information on that
thank you Council field so I struggling
with the buttons there for a second um
so I picked up on two questions there
the first one was around succession um
uh passing of a tendency onto another
person on the event of the death
and that is covered in uh in section
11.2 of the policy prefers to succession
and specifically that succession can
only happen once to a tenancy
um so it can only
be born at once so any subsequent
passing away of the tenant who's
succeeded the tenancy already doesn't
then that any other occupant doesn't
have a right to the tenancy
um but we will treat will that treat
that situation since to be obviously we
are in the business of housing people
um support them we have we um we
understand the circumstances of whoever
remains in a property will have a legal
right to that tenancy or not
um and to announce that appropriately um
um and the second question was sort of
linked to that
um was around relationship breakdown
and what happens if if a couple who have
a joint tenancy uh separate and one one
party ends the tendency for both
um that is a matter of law not something
you have any discretion over that is a
[Music]
one of the intricacies of
um
the the secure tenancies that
are periodic in nature they can be it
ended by either party at any time and
the policy makes provision for that
under Section 11.11 persons residing in
the property at the end of a tenancy so
again that refers to a similar situation
just described in the succession
example in that we have a person living
in a property um you know we are a very
person-centered service um and we'll
make sure those people are handled
appropriately and their needs assessed
in either that housing
very much
um Council Willem
yeah thank you chair it's a question
around 10.4
um to show save everybody looking at it
says if a tenant is unable to end their
tendency themselves for any reason there
is no power of attorney in place then a
suitable person needs to be appointed by
the office of the public Guardian which
is all very clear but
um I've had occasions when a tenant has
gone into Residential Care
they don't want to end their tenancy but
they don't want to live there
they're just not in a they're not in a
mental state in order to enter to end
their tenancy and
um the
I think it was the daughter and the
son-in-law
had a great deal of difficulty getting
any help as to what they what they could
do about it so but my question is
could could we ensure that there's like
some notes for guidance that's available
so that
um people in that position or similar
positions can just be said look this is
what you need to do because it took them
about three weeks to find out what they
needed to do
so I mean my just my request is can we
have some clarification that's available
in writing for people in that position
yes I'm sure we can sort that out
does anybody wish to debate this
I.T this is a
we have to do it if we if we want our
residents to have
happy happy communities
then restricting the life of their
tenancy is not going to achieve that and
so uh
the way we need to go to make sure that
all our residents are living in happy
healthy communities so I'm very happy to
support this
um so the recommendation is to approve
the tenancy policy in appendix a and I'm
going to invite the governance officer
to conduct the vote
thank you chair that brought us now in
progress
let's hope for thank
councilor Fleming may I have your vote
please
thank you
chair that is six works for and that's
unanimous
thank you item 11 is MCA slash 22 37 the
Freeport East business rates policies
we have with us uh Fiona Duhamel the
director of economic growth and climate
change and we've also got Michelle
Gordon the corporate manager for economy
and business for this and we invite the
cabinet member for economic growth to
introduce this report Council Richardson
lovely thank you very much chair
um I would like to introduce paper MCA
slash 22-37 at the Freeport East
business rates policies and to propose
the recommendations
Airport
for the benefit of anyone watching the
live stream I've just noticed I'm not
the cabinet member for health and
well-being I'm the cabinet member for
economic growth as you said in your
introduction just just for clarity
um however within the report
um chair I would like to make one
amendment to recommendation 3.1 to the
memorandum of understanding be endorsed
in consultation with the cabinet members
for economic growth and for finance so
that's myself and councilor Whitehead
um as members will be aware the council
is a founding partner of Freeport East
limited and a major beneficiary of the
Freeport given the inclusion of Gateway
14 as a tax site and potential custom
site
the government approved the outline
business case for Freeport East in
December 2021 and is considering the
full business case after its submission
last year
and cabinet may remember that we agreed
to endorse this business case uh
SGA
as part of the Freeport and therefore is
one of the billing authorities
mid-suffolk District Council is required
to have both a business rates relief
policy and a retained rates policy
this will allow us to manage and
appropriately allocate the retained
rates that the council receives as a
result of businesses locating to the
Gateway 14 tax site and toward up to 100
relief on business rates for qualifying
businesses
in addition we are also asking cabinet
to authorize the monitoring officer and
the director for economic growth and
climate change in consultation with the
relevant cabinet members to endorse a
memorandum of understanding between
ourselves and central government on
behalf of the council again this is
something we are required to do as one
of the billing authorities within the
Freeport however this is also
significant as this is essential for the
Freeport becoming fully operational
itself and accessing sea capital of in
our case six million pounds which will
provide funding towards the development
of the skills and Innovation Center at
Gateway 14 and other Net Zero projects
uh further detail on the business rates
relief policy and retaining rates policy
can be found in the appendices along
with a template memorandum of
understanding for information
um and I'm therefore happy to propose
the amended recommendations 3.1 3.2 and
3.3 I would ask
thank you chair
thank you councilor Richard Richardson
we have a second
counselor wanted
um yes I'm happy to Second this report
um
the Freeport status and business rate
relief
deals with it is I think vital
vital to the attraction of the Gateway
14 site in mid-suffolk and I think so I
think the principles were fairly
straightforward but um I would say that
I'm happy that um we have got obviously
the color of Michelle and Melissa to go
through the devil of the detail which is
covered in all these various appendices
because they uh it doesn't seem to be
remarkably complicated thank you
thank you do we have any questions
you know cancel with him
sure you'd be disappointed if I didn't
wouldn't you really
um could could you look at the reason
for the decision please because I'm
trying to understand that a bit better
and we've heard that there's potentially
six million pounds
um which
could be leveraged I guess the word
would be
um for us the skills and Innovation
Center
so
um can you give us a a figure around
what substantial additional funding is
and
is this towards
the delivery of Gateway 14 or isn't that
already sorted out so what is the you
know what would it be spent on we see
here infrastructure and investment
projects in The Wider area
so I mean are we talking about
the whole of mid-suffer or bigger than
mid-suffer or what are we talking about
there
um
and
I I wonder what is meant by true
inclusive growth for our communities
when a lot of businesses in The Stone
Market area are saying that they are
placed at a disadvantage
um as a result of Gateway 14 and the tax
breaks and everything else so they don't
feel they feel completely excluded not
included so could I could I ask what re
what what what I can say to them when
they complain about being excluded
thank you
thank you chair thank you councilor
welcome for that question in terms of
the the first part of that question I
may need to refer to offices for their
advice on on some of the exact specifics
of the funding in terms of what we mean
by inclusive growth I think it's worth
just reflecting on the criteria for
be designated and qualified for these um
benefits associated with the Freeport
the
the part of it as a tax site it would
need to be a business that meets
specific criteria around expanding
either because they need more space or
more staff it's it's not something that
can simply apply to any business that
wishes to relocate in terms of the
businesses that will be at every Gateway
14. obviously members will be aware that
we only have
um at the moment this stage the range
publicly confirmed as far as I'm aware
there isn't a business in Stone Market
that would be a competitor of the range
either in its size or in the exact
operations it undertakes so I I don't
necessarily agree that they are too
um the get me 14 is something that would
threaten existing businesses in that way
and
in terms of the the specifics of the
finances I'll hand over to officers if I
may to answer that aspect thank you
Misha
thank you again cancers
in terms of the financial investment
that comes alongside the Freeport East
designation the primary
um Finance the primary benefit that's
been referenced by councilor Richardson
so far is the seed Capital funding which
will be released on the approval of the
full business case so for Gateway
Fortune as mentioned that's up to 6
million pounds for the towards the
development of the Innovation and Skills
Center and additional Net Zero
Investments the other Financial
incentive that's available for us and
that is slightly more substantial is
the retained business rates and that's
part of the reason why we have the
retained rates policy
um come to Cabinet this morning as well
we've done some initial modeling working
alongside the Freeport East colleagues
that looks at the development potential
for Gateway 14 over the next 25 years
the part of the benefit of the Freeport
East designation is that we retain up to
100 of the business rates for those 25
years in a similar way to the Enterprise
Zone
designation that we've had previously
the early models suggest that
potentially up to 145 million would be
generated by Gateway 14 over that
25-year period
I have to caveat that with a lot of
um um
uncertainty around the potential
business rates
um
income
the fact that we are looking at
projections on the size of the the units
that could be developed what the
valuation office might charge those itat
and when their developments might
actually happen so it does come with
with some uncertainty however we are
looking at a substantial amount of
Revenue that could be generated through
retained business rates the retained
rates policy that's included in the
cabinet papers
poses that 35 of those business rates
would be retained by the council as part
of what we're calling pop B
for the reinvestment in Gateway 14 for
further
um commercial development so enabling
further investment in The Innovation
Skills Center and other
projects on site that could support the
expansion of the of the program at
particularly in relation to and to
Business Development
their element is pot C which is around
the 30 percent
and that's where the wider benefits come
into the um come into play the 30
percent of the business rates revenues
go into The Wider pulled pot for Access
for all businesses across the Freeport
region the Freeport East priority for
those is around investment in Innovation
skills and and
Innovation and Net Zero and
we will be working alongside Freeport
East colleagues in order to identify
particular projects for those but they
are not specifically only to be
delivered on the Freeport East tax sites
they are available across higher
frequency
thank you councilor field
uh just a question I did notice Port one
got a couple of words in this document
to what extent are these issues apply to
that site as well we're always a bit
confused whether it's a tax site or a
custom site only but the issue that it
must generate substantial revenues as
well
so yeah but you you all
the discussions seem to talk about
Gateway 14 and Gateway 14 only so to
what extent is there a
transfer of these benefits across both
sides
I'm with without I don't wish to say
something which may be incorrect so I
think I'm going to I think I know the
answer but I'm going to head over to two
offices just to confirm
yes so Port one is included within the
Freeport East designation as a custom
site as opposed to a tax site so the tax
sites are the only sites that generate
retained rates revenues the
coach include the retained rates
um policy however the Ben the businesses
that locate on a custom site can access
other Financial incentives directly from
government in relation to
um Customs tariff access to customs
tariffs so we're working with the owners
of Port one to look at how their
businesses on that site can benefit from
those those reliefs
thank you thank you everybody
does anybody wish to debate this item
yes
delegated authorities given to the
monitoring officer in consultation with
the director for economic growth and
climate change to endorse the memorandum
of understanding of
the cabinet approves the Freeport East
retained rates policy with authority be
given to the council's section 151
officer in consultation with the
operations manager SRP and the director
for economic growth and climate change
to make changes to the policy in
consultation with the relevant portfolio
holders to ensure it meets the criteria
set by the council and in line with
updated government guidance
and 3.3 the cabinet approves the
business rate relief policy with
authority being given to the council's
section 151 officer in consultation with
the operations manager for SRP and
for economic growth and climate change
to make changes to the policy in
consultation with the relevant portfolio
holders to ensure it meets the criteria
set by the council and in line with up
guidance
guidance and for the avoidance of doubt
the relevant
cabinet members or the cabinet member
for economic growth and climate change
and the cabinet member for finance
so I'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote just to note
on the first recommendation that's also
in consultation
so the items
sorry Clause 3.1 in cludes the relevant
portfolio holders
yes
the recommendation's correct now so the
vote should now be in progress
councilor headingham I'd like to vote
for thank you thank you councilor
thank you chair that is six votes for
and that's unanimous
thank you very much
moving on now to item 12.
this is MCA slash 22-38 the scrutiny and
cabinet protocol
we have with us uh Jan Robinson who's
the culture corporate manager for
governance and city of
and I'm going to invite Jane to
introduce this report thank you Jen
thank you chair
um this protocol has been formulated
following recommendations from the
corporate peer review and is considered
best practice by the center for
governance and scrutiny
the protocol clearly defines the role of
overview and scrutiny cabinet and
offices and promotes a culture of
accountability openness and transparency
whilst recognizing the key role of
overview and scrutiny as a key enabler
within that culture overviewing the
scrutiny committee have already agreed
the protocol at their meeting in
December I'm happy to take any questions
thank you
thank you I'm happy to propose this do
we have a seconder
cancer Fleming I'm happy to Second this
paper thank you thank you thank you very
much
um does anybody have any questions
um yes a question on
how freak how the protocol will be
reviewed
dated going forward what sort of sort of
see and
um you know procedure will be used to
make this happen
thank you chair so um initially we'll
wait and see how the actual protocol
beds in we're having meetings monthly
meetings with the cabinet and the chairs
above the unscrutiny
um and we can review that at a point
once the actual protocol has been bedded
in to see how it's working it will be
part of that agenda
um on a probably six monthly basis and
then we'll take it back to
um scrutiny and cabinet if we need to
review it or add to it if it's felt that
is necessary
thank you does anybody else have any
questions
no okay so anybody wish to debate
no
the recommendations are
cabinet approves this scrutiny cabinet
protocol which is attached
um
governance officer to conduct the vote
thank you
thank you chair the votes land progress
councilor harringham I'd like to vote
for thank you councilor Fleming
that is unanimous gym thank you very
much
item 13. is NCAA 22-39
is our risk management Improvement and
we have with us Jane Kennedy who's the
Strategic policy performance insight and
risk manager and we've also got Theresa
Fairburn who's a risk management lead
with us
um I'm the cabinet member for this
um
so in April 2021 our external audit
Partners TIAA undertook a review
of our strategic risk management
Arrangements
they identified some good practice in
our risk management framework and also
made recommendations to improve
including an updated risk management
strategy
this report updates members on risk
management Improvement since
responsibility for this risk transferred
to the policy performance Insight risk
and Improvement team in January this
year
following this change SLT agreed to
adopt a whole system's approach to risk
management known as the government's
orange book
this government approach will help us to
improve the culture and Leadership of
risk management across the councils
in March 2022 the councils also received
feedback on our approach to risk
management
in the LGA corporate peer challenge
report
one of their recommendations was to
revisit the risk management strategy and
entering it to life
to ensure a more effective corporate
approach to risk including Financial
Risk
members of The Joint audit and standards
committee on 28th of November were asked
to consider the effectiveness of the
revised risk management strategy to
deliver the appropriate risk management
Arrangements
the new strategy includes the main
recommendations made by the TIAA and the
LGA and embeds the government orange
book risk management principles
the recommendation to embed the strategy
sorry the recommendation to embed the
council's risk appetite will be reviewed
further following the May elections and
will be embedded when the strategy is
reviewed again in November 23.
the strategy is supported by an
improvement program to embed risk across
the councils establishing a positive
culture of risk management and
continuous Improvement
foreign
audit and standards committee members
raised that they would like to see
further Assurance in terms of companies
risk management as a consequence a
change was made to the strategy at
section five
under company level to note that the
company's risk panel meets each quarter
to review their risks with the council's
risk management lead
company risks are reflected on the
Strategic risk register where required
going forward the annual risk management
report to Joint audit and standards
committee will provide Assurance as the
company's risk management Arrangements
joint cabinet reviewed the paper on
December the 12th and were supportive of
both the work to date and the proposed
new strategy
cabinet members with their
responsibility for strategic risk
management and approval of the joint
risk management policy and strategy are
kindly asked to note the progress so far
to improve strategic risk management and
to agree the new draft risk management
policy and strategy which aligns with
the orange book
thank you councilors and I'll call for a
second
Mr Richardson chair thank you
do we have any questions from cabinet
any questions from anybody else
has anybody wish to debate this item
councilor Richardson
thank you chair I'll just make a a
couple of brief comments obviously I
think I'm well I entirely support
um this risk management strategy and the
sort of the underlying thinking behind
it obviously we as a counselor in a
reasonably fortuitous position where
we're undertaking a sort of a number of
quite large
um
projects Gateway 14 being one shelf
being another which does carry and they
do carry inherent risks both Financial
legal reputational and so I think it's
very important that we have a risk
management plan that is up to date that
is robust
um but actually what I particularly see
this is that cycle of continuous
Improvement so although we have to
manage and mitigate and identify these
risks that shouldn't stop us from moving
forward and delivering on our
aspirations as a council which are
fairly significant in some areas so I
thoroughly welcome this report and we'll
be voting for it thank you chair
thank you councilor Richardson
councilor Fleming
um yes thank you I just wanted to add to
that um you know there are a lot of
big programs coming up here in baber and
mid-suffolk and um you know we had a
previous paper on the role of overview
and scrutiny and I think that um
maybe going forward the scrutiny work
could usefully focus a little bit on the
overview function as well and look at
some of these strategic projects going
forward in a way that you know benefits
the council and and the public
um and shows that we're doing our job in
in looking hard at the things that are
important
so the recommendation is that members of
the mid-suffer cabinet are asked to note
the progress so far to improve strategic
risk management and to agree the new
draft risk management policy and
strategy which aligns with the orange
book
I could ask the governance officer to
conduct the vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress councilor headingham I'd like
to vote for thank you thank you very
much Council Fleming Paul thank you
thank you chair that is six votes four
that's unanimous thank you
excellent well
that concludes our business for today
so the next meeting is scheduled for
Monday the 6th of February at 10 30.